what is the worst thing about Jeb Bush I
have the worst thing about Jeb Bush is
that in the end he's probably not going
to do it I have this sneaking suspicion
early so you ready to run now I have
this I have the sneaking suspicion and
watch me be completely proven wrong they
think of their no cameras here to report
it that you know for all the all the
guts that I've just attributed to him
he's going to realize at some point that
being a bush is just too much of a
problem for this electorate and he can't
do it and frankly he doesn't want to go
through all of that crap and I think
he's his own I think he thinks he's his
own man with his own reputation and if
he's not going to win the presidency if
he's gonna be embarrassed he's not going
to do it I think that's what's going
through his mind now I think that's why
he came out of the box very enthusiastic
and yet he's still not announce
candidate following his own time time
schedule you know I know his his staff
hates when people say that you know he
doesn't have that fire in the belly to
run and be President you know I have a
sneaking suspicion though that in the
end you know he's just gonna say you
know what not for me is part of that
though just sort of the reality of it
which is even this week his people were
saying he's probably not even gonna go
to Iowa regardless whether you know
right so is assuming he runs that he's
probably not gonna go right because that
doesn't really give him a good path but
didn't that screw Giuliani aware the
other thing is is there plenty of ish I
mean when he forget if his name was Jeff
Smith okay yeah Jeff this is a guy Jeff
Smith we're talking about Governor flora
Jeff Smith who is in favor of Common
Core which is in half image of the
Republican base whose positions on
immigration although he's trying to walk
them back our way to the left of where
the the center of gravity in the party
is who was said I'm not going to
compromise my beliefs to win the primary
before so we kind of faced a pretty
difficult challenge from the start well
I think the answer there is that the
best thing about Jeb Bush is the family
name and also the worst thing about Jeb
Bush is the family and but is he going
to run at all we have it on video tape
let us know your thoughts in the
comments right now